anyway and the Germans please insure me
that will have a humorous yet efficient
evening so I can get to my game on time
we gettin we gonna share half maybe
that's right everyone here as far as you
know that's right that's why we hang out
in Venezuela that's right because
they're bad extradition policies there
yes no Nazis here no that's like I mean
right that's right
anyway a mark somatic mark mark ceramic
mark so it's catchy you're right but
yeah beside that you missed your game
yeah but it turns out the Germans are
not big hockey fans we don't really care
so much ix we like to play other games
in Germany yeah like world war is a good
one that we like we invented that one
pretty much that's us yeah also that we
put people on ice it's something
completely if you're there sir yeah
there's no second period for those
people just a long time oh we were so
bad she put Azizi piano deep oh yeah
yeah it's called the nuremberg trials
which is a joke from the forties you can
look that one up as well you want to
google that if you want I feel bad you
lost you missed your game but here's the
upside you have an evening with your
lovely wife Christina yeah which is
unencumbered why you need to play game
with sweaty other men and you bump into
them and rub up against them in the
locker room saying Oh where's your stick
oh here's my stick it's between your
Tupac's my gat you just made me hard so
welcome here and Gooden couldn't you
couldn't night
knocks knock death result knocked and
I'm sure now is that you've missed your
game your wife will let you comb and
just shoot it right in the five hole
that means a posse yeah yeah make sure
she posts the goalie beforehand that's
all I'm asking for you yes what you can
have a baby if they pull the goalie so
to speak there's a lots of Shoeless
imagine if we deceive I read the same
good knock
[Music]